لابد انك تابعت ما يدور حول الانتخابات
الامريكيه اجل ما الذي تفعله الان هل تعمل
على برنامج جديد نعم حول السياسه
الامريكيه اجل وهو من انتاج فيوجن وسيحمل
اسم دليل الديمقراطيه وسيكون عباره عن
نظره حيل السياسه الامريكيه من منظور شرق
اوسطي وكيف ترى الامور انت خاصه وانكم قد
انتقلت من ميدان التحرير الى حكم مرسي
ومنه الى النظام العسكري حاليا فكيف تقارن
الاوضاع مع امريكا هناك عده قضايا فمثلا
كنت اقوم بتغطيه مسيره للمرشح دونالد
ترامب انت تظهر هنا بلافته تقول الاغلبيه
الصامته تقف مع ترامب كنت اقف هناك واحسست
بان كراهيه الاجانب والمشاعر الديماغوجي
قد جرفني فتصرفت وكانني في منزلي وكيف ترى
الامور من منظور كوميدي خاصه انه يريد حظر
دخول المسلمين الى
امريكا لا يخيفني ما قاله ترامب بمقدار ما
يخيفني تقبل الناس للامر ترامب مجرد رجل
واحد المشكله انه بمواقفه اعطى صوتا لمن
لا صوت لهم وهم الناس الذين تملاه مشاعر
الغضب والكراهيه فكانهم باتوا يقولون هذا
الرجل غبي ويمكنني ان اكون غبيا
مثله المشكله هي هناك امر يزعجني اكثر
بقضيه ترامب وهو لا يتعلق به فهو ربما
يقوم بهذا الامر لاجل الاستعراض الاعلامي
لكن تاد كروز روبيو يقومان بذلك عن قناعه
ربما لا يعبران عن موقفهما بشكل غبي لكن
طريقتهما لا تقول خطوره بل هي اخطر في
الواقع
وكيف تربط الامور بما يجري في بلدك مصر
وفي سائر انحاء
العالم الامر متطابق فهذا خوف مجتمعي خوف
من الاخرين والاعتقاد بوجود مؤامره وهميه
وان الجميع يخططون لا استهدافنا وان علينا
ان نكون اقوياء وندمر الجميع لان الجميع
يحاربنا الامر مماثل
تماما هناك صور لك ايضا ضمن مشروع دليل
الديمقراطيات خاصتك تظهر فيه وانت بطريقك
لمتجر سلاح فلماذا ذهبت الى هناك ولماذا
تظهر وانت تحمل بندقيه ذهبت الى هناك
لانني اردت ان ادخل ذهنيا في ثقافه السلاح
فعندما نتحدث مع اصحاب الاسلحه يقولون
انها للصيد ثم يتضح وجود اسلحه اليه واخرى
متطوره كاسحه حرب النجوم وعندما تسالهم عن
ذلك يقولون لا يمكن لاحد اخذ اسلحتنا منا
فهو في حمدنا النووي كيف تعتبرون الشرق
الاوسط منطقه عنيفه اذا الامر غير منطقي
ابدا doesn't make sense